من غازي عنتاب احمد رحمه من منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود اهلا بك كيف هو الواقع الطبي
والاستشفائي والدواء في اليوم الثامن قبل
قبيل انتهائه
اهلا بكم وبساده المشاهدين في قناه
العربيه اخي الكريم للاسف يعاني قطاع
الصحي في شمال غرب سوريا من من كارثه
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
القطاع الصحي تعرض لتدمير ممنهج خلال 12
سنه الماضيه
دمرت معظم المنشات الصحيه
بالوضع الصحي كارثي الامدادات الصحيه في
وضع صعب جدا معظم المنشات الصحيه تعاني من
نقص شديد في التمويل وفي الامدادات الطبيه
منذ اليوم الاول كان هناك حاجه شديده
لامداد معظم المنشات الصحيه بالعديد من
المواد منذ اليوم الاول عدد كبير من
المنشات الصحيه لم تكفيها
المستودعات الموجوده لديها لتقطيط المرضى
في اليوم الاول اليوم نحن في اليوم الثامن
ولا زالت الامتدادات الصحيه من مواد اوليه
ومستهلكات طبيه وادويه ومعدات طبيه قليله
الوصول الى الداخل في شمال غرب سوريا ما
زلنا نتحدث في منظمه اطباء بلا حدود نركز
اكثر على ما الذي استطعتم ان تقدموه حتى
الان في مختلف المناطق المتضرره
حقيقه نحن منذ اليوم الاول
فتحنا معظم جميع مستودعاتنا والموجود من
المستودعاتنا كافه المنشات الطبيه العامله
في جمال غرب سوريا
بالمواد الطبيه المتوفره لدينا من
مستهلكات طبيه وادويه لانقاذ الجرحى
ومعالجه المصابين ولكن يعني علينا ان نشير
انها لا تكفي قد تكون نقطه في بحر من
الاحتياجات الضخمه التي يحتاجها المنشات
الصحيه في شمال سوريا
ما اهم ما يحتاجه الناس هناك الان ما
دعوتكم ولمن
للاسف كل شيء يحتاج الناس للناس فقدوا
بيوتهم فقدوا منازلهم فقدوا ارزاقهم فقدوا
احبائهم فقدوا كل شيء كل ما يقدم هو هو
يعني يعتبر احتياجات اساسيه الناس في
العراء للاسف اخي الناس فقدت بيوتها فقد
احبابها
في هذا يعني تسلسل الكوارث على الشعب
السوري خلال الفتره الاخيره خلينا نقول
يعني من شتاء قارص من موجه ثلوج من اصابات
من اغلاق المعابر من الان كارثه الزلزال
التي قد تكون كارثه القرن حقيقه كلها
كوارث تاتي على راس الشعب السوري
الاحتياجات طبيه شديده جدا كبيره جدا حتى
اليوم نحن نتحدث عن اليوم اقتراب يوم
التاسع من الكارثه وما زالت المنشات
الصحيه تعاني من نقص شديد في الاحتياجات
وادخالات المواد عبر الحدود لا تزال في
كميات ضئيله جدا نتحدث عن بضع شاحنات من
الا التي دخلت عبر الحدود وهذا رقم جدا
ضئيل من هنا من هذا المنبر علينا ان نشير
للضروره فتح المعابر لضروره ان لا يكون
الامر مقتصر على معبر واحد الادخالات انه
قد تكون قليله جدا
معلش نركز معك اكثر لو تكرمت على الطبيعه
الادويه التي تحتاجونها
والاطباء الذين تحتاجون تحتاجونهم وطبيعه
الاصابات التي نتجت الخوذه البيضاء تتحدث
الان عن اكثر من اثني عشر الف مصاب فقط في
الشمال الغربي لسوريا حيث المناطق
المتضرره
نعم اخي الاحتياجات يعني اليوم نتحدث
بدايه كنا نتحدث عن احتياجات في
الاصابات
الناتجه عن ردود ناتجه عن سقوط المنازل
والمباني
المواد التجهيزات
المتعلقه بالجراحه العظميه والجراحه
العامه والمشافي
ولكن بعد تجاوز هذه المرحله نحن نحتاج
لاعاده بناء الصحه الاوليه الصحه النفسيه
الصحه النفسيه الوضع كارثه في سوريا الان
طبعا من الحرب الوضع كارثي للاسف والصحه
الاوليه كذلك بالاضافه الى ان الناس
كبير في الاطباء نفسيين بدون شك
بدون شكوى كح كبير في الكوادر الطبيه
تتحدث للاسف عن عن اكثر من قرابه المئه
دوله اعلنت استجابتها للكارثه الطرف من
الحدود ولكن من الطرق اخر من الحدود لا
يوجد احد للاسف يعني قد لا يتجاوز اصابع
اليد الواحده الدول التي استجابت في شمال
غرب سوريا يعني هناك لجوء لطرق البدائيه
في في تطبيب وفي العلاج الان
تماما يعني الامر ينعكس من الدفاع المدني
عمليات الانقاذ تبدا عمليات انقاذ من خلال
الادوات اليدويه البسيطه لانقاذ وكذلك
الامر يعني ينسحب على المجال الطبي للاسف
في بعض المشافي وبعض المنشات الطبيه يكاد
الكوادر تعمل بالحدود الدنيا للمعايير
الطبيه والسبب ليس ليس سوء من من الكوادر
الطبيه ولكن لا يوجد لديها ايه امكانيات
لاكمال لاكمال العمل بشكل افضل تمام يعني
من هذا ندعو الى فتح ايصال
يكفيه الشعب السوري ما عانى خلال 12 سنه
واعتقد انه الان الوقت المناسب اليوم
كارثه على على في منطقه جغرافيه واحده
نرجو ليكفي خزلان للشعب الكوري في هذا
الامر شكرا جزيلا لك احمد رحمه من منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود من غازي عنتاب تحياتي اليك